let's get more now on the shooting in
California where the police have
confirmed that 10 people have died in a
mass shooting during Chinese New Year's
celebrations or joining me now is Carli
chick who's a journalist and an
analytics professional based in Los
Angeles it's good to have you with us
just bring us up to date with the latest
that you're hearing
so far from our local news sources we
haven't had much of an update
um since the briefing I think about an
hour ago
and the police in the press conference
earlier on saying that they don't yet
have a motive for the attack but what
are you hearing from people that you're
speaking to who were around the scene
um so I think it's very hard to say on
what exactly the motive could be I think
there's still a lot of confusion a lot
of shock and a lot of fear that's within
our community so there isn't much in
terms of speculation for what the motive
could have been I think most of us are
in Shock that this could have happened
at all
do you know anything at all about the
victims in terms of age for example the
youngest victim for example
um I'm actually not sure about
um the youngest victim but I know in
terms of the age range is anywhere from
40s to 80s 40 to 80s year year olds
and so far we know that 10 people have
died are you hearing any further
information on that at all has that
death toll increased
no as far as I'm aware uh we haven't had
any updated numbers just that
um some who were rushed to the hospital
are still in critical condition
and so what's the move there then the
people you're speaking to that there
must be there must be a loss of shock
going through the community we know that
the lunar year Festival in the area has
also been canceled just tell us about
the mood at the moment and what you're
hearing from people the reaction
yeah it's it's been pretty solemn and I
think most of us are pretty fearful in
terms of the people I've talked to so
far um in my circle many of us who have
grown up in Monterey Park since we were
children went to high school middle
school in the area are just in complete
shock right now it's um 4 52 in the
morning for us in Los Angeles
um and this happened at around 10 30 p.m
the previous day and so you know earlier
um on Saturday it was quite festive we
were all very hopeful and very cheerful
so in in uh in terms of context uh this
Lunar New Year Festival has been
canceled since 2020 because of the
covid-19 pandemic this would Mark the
first year that this Lunar New Year
celebration would have returned and
earlier everyone was very happy you know
being able to spend time with their
family their friends out in the open and
eating together and you know as of this
news which I think most people didn't
find out until midnight they were pretty
shocked I can only speak for myself that
it's um been pretty rough and a little
hard to sleep and I'll pick up on
something that you said just a moment
ago that a lot of people are pretty
fearful what is it that can be done do
you think to alleviate that fear within
the community
um I think knowing more information on
the um the shooter would really help I
think right now we
have no information at all other than
what has happened the numbers of the
number of victims but we essentially
have no other information
um
knowing a motive would really help but
also knowing any more information would
help as well we just don't have anything
that we know and it's all been
speculation and of course not to trust
everything that you see on the internet
there's been quite a lot that we've been
reading and of course we don't believe
everything that we read and of course I
can understand the fear and the
frustration because when the police um
spoke earlier on we heard from Andrew
Mayer from the LA
um Sheriff's homicide team who also said
they don't even have a description of
the suspect
that's right that's right we
um and I know in an abundance of caution
they had canceled the festivities for
tomorrow but I think what is driving
most of the fear in our community is
that the shooter is still at large and
we have no description no real way to
um I think protect ourselves in terms of
what can we possibly do as a community
okay collegeik thank you very much
indeed journalists and analytics
professional based in Los Angeles thank
you very much